c'est l'attraction de tous les touristes
depuis quelques jours vous savez ce que
c'est oui et c'est une poubelle enfants
de pied par ce fait très beau c'est une
très bonne idée
des poubelles original mais aussi des
trottoirs qui brille et des bons tout
juste sorti du sinn
après dix mois de travaux le centre
ville de saint-claude fait peau neuve
je trouve ça fait du bien ça leur fait
les geishas scène on sait très bien
c'est toujours difficile dans une ville
de circuler à pied là c'est vrai qu'on a
un bel espace pour les piétons et c'est
bien pour les commerces aussi d'ailleurs
ces derniers se porte plutôt bien
la gérante de ce restaurant fait le
plein tous les jours notamment grâce à
sa nouvelle terrasse avant ça s'arrêtait
juste et si il y avait un mètre et puis
de l'autre côté il y avait tous ces
plats à la rue avec la pierre il est
vraiment pas bête du tout ces nouvelles
villes voilà qui est des mars et je suis
très très content y a rien à dire car
avec la fermeture de plusieurs services
de l'hôpital et les nombreuses
disparitions d'entreprises saint claude
a perdu plus de 2000 habitants en dix
ans pour la mairie la revitalisation de
ce centre ville était une nécessité
nami deux millions et demi de travaux
dans ce centre ville pour d'abord
essentiellement réactive et l'activité
commerciale et ça je pense que
les reprises de forme de pas-de-porte
devrait se faire de manière naturelle
tant donné que le centre-ville beaucoup
plus attractifs depuis la rentrée trois
commerces ont déjà réouvert leurs portes
le centre ville de saint-claude sera
exceptionnellement piétons ce samedi à
l'occasion de l'inauguration